Estoy muy emocionada no puedo sentir los
latidos de mi corazón todavía Creo que
ganaremos
como unas elecciones de infarto Ese es
el sentir del pueblo
turcoin simpatizante el candidato
opositor que mal cristal oglu no pudo
dormir en casa esperando los resultados
y prefirió ir a la sede del partido de
quilishdaroglu en Estambul para
supervisar el conteo de votos como mujer
quiero Este cambio la situación del país
es obvio
cada voto cuenta en este momento cuando
el centro izquierdista que
malquistaroglu está tan cerca de regieta
y everton según la agencia oficial de
noticias turca con unos resultados
preliminares tan ajustados en las filas
de la oposición el temor ante un
eventual fraude es grande
ha denunciado irregularidades en
estambuliankara las dos principales
ciudades del país y donde el apoyo a un
cambio es claro
300 urnas en ankara y 783 en Estambul
tienen objeciones persistentes
se está bloqueando la voluntad de
Turquía no pueden bloquear lo que va a
suceder nunca aceptaremos que el
resultado de esta elección ya es un
hecho consumado
el ambiente desde el oficialismo ya es
festivo pero el presidente erdoan admite
que aún falta para la victoria con las
elecciones del 14 de mayo en nuestro
país ha completado otra fiesta de la
Democracia con una Clara ventaja
por su parte sinanogan tercero en la
contienda y afina erdoan dijo que su
electorado determinará los resultados